warwickshire dad builds wooden votes
it's his livelihood and his passion for
more than 20 years now he's been
repairing old yachts in his workshop and
neend off on the baltic coast it's hard
physical labor although it hasn't made
him rich Ulrich loves his job discovered
us on amia here by the sea and slays big
hosteen you can do and experience so
much if you feel about to the editing of
and that makes up for a lot of the
material things I think you need less
here so you're happier with less medina
go quickly the beach the sea and the
vast open space it's here in abundance
in schleswig-holstein that might be why
surveys show people in northern germany
are happier than anywhere else in the
country researchers believe it's because
family friends and home outweigh the
luxuries that money provides you don't
have to look any further than gluck stat
or lucky town it's part of the greater
Hamburg area but with just 11 thousand
residents life in group shot is far
removed from the hustle and bustle of
the big city mayor gerhard Blasberg
believes happiness is quite simple mon
cala d'or shot you can actually breathe
deeply here it's a karma and healthier
pace of life but we still have all the
infrastructure and culture you need so
you can't say we're really in the sticks
here either get heaps of oil just like
the oka mark region here in brandenburg
in eastern Germany the windswept
landscape dotted with lakes in quaint
towns draws in artists and tourists from
near and far but for some reason the
people who live here aren't that happy
in fact statistically they're the least
happy in Germany that has the district
administrator deep my shirt so worried
in the small city of prenzlauer he's
trying to find political solutions to
the region's problems to make residents
here just a little
been happier but the population is
shrinking and young people are leaving
in droves because in peer-to-peer a
lager we're on the outskirts of the
community here on Thomas montreux and
that's unfortunately led to very high
unemployment rates often long-term
unemployment and done this is a human
it's a problem that plagues us wicklund
transia here Catalina Boudreaux Simon
was forced to leave the Brandenburg
countryside in search of work years
later she decided to return with her
husband and child but she's a rare
exception laughter shula's a few a lot
of young people left the ochre mark
after they finish school I think their
relatives and family who are left behind
are often says that their children and
grandchildren live so far away it's hard
to really create that sense of family
compo I Nexus 4 million Liam needs a
rookie to stand up here in gluck start
though not too many people leave in fact
a lot of residents compromise and juggle
their careers to live here because they
want to that adds to the sense of
harmony just we know who identify cuts
on God's people really identify with
their town and that really helps the
work atmosphere and sense of community
they don't feel like it's a chore they
don't expect politicians or the city to
take care of them they take
responsibility for themselves Ulric
shutter is content building boats here
in schleswig-holstein he believes the
recipe for happiness is easy you have to
stick to your hometown through the good
times and the bad even when things don't
go your way as the fishermen here no
well
mcclure click where the happiest people
in the world as long as we don't have to
stay home that's where the happiness
ends I'm happy when there are fish in my
net fishing in that sahaja ulrich
shutters last piece of advice wherever
you live don't think too hard about
being happy just be